- I'm sort of thinking about
all of the people that I know.
That I have a relationship
and a history with.
And people don't know
them like I know them.
You know, I mean Gwyneth Paltrow,
who's one of my early guests,
will be when this comes out,
I've known her since she
was sixteen years old.
- Wow!
- When my wife and I were first together,
Gwyneth was living in my guest bedroom,
trying to get an agent.
So, I'm going to be
able to talk to people.
- That's a crazy story.
- Yeah yeah, but that's,
just the beginning.
You know, whether it's Alec Baldwin,
and the time he tried to
get me sober on the beach.
When I was at the height
of my crazy partying,
or you know, whether it's Magic Johnson.
Reminiscing about the fact
that Pat Reilly banned me,
from staying at the same
hotel as the Lakers.
I mean, it's been 40 years of doing this.
And you know, I get Mike Myers on,
or I get Chris Pratt on.
And we're gonna have a
connection and a history.
That no one else is gonna have.
- How do you break down their walls?
Cause a lot of people get reserved,
you know or they get
kind of like calculated,
cause they're like, am
I supposed to say this,
or not supposed to say this.
And there's that kinship,
that friendship that I think
is really important that your
podcast is gonna bring out.
A side of people we haven't really seen.
But speaking of all those times,
wasn't there a story also
about you and Tom Cruise?
Spending the night together
in a stranger's house?
Cause I need to know more about that.
- Yeah, well the way you say it,
makes it more interesting.
- Yeah.
- Almost an even better story.
(Kelly laughs)
What I want, with just that
headline and no context,
I'm imagining such--
- I have gone to so many places,
and I'm into any of them.
- Yeah, well for sure.
So no, what happened was,
when we were doing The Outsiders,
we're 18 and 19 years old,
it's Francis Ford Coppola, the director.
Who directed The Godfather
and Apocalypse Now,
and the most intense kind
of director imaginable.
And in his effort to
make us more authentic as Greasers,
as sort of tough Tulsa sort of,
you know, wrong-side-of-the-tracks guys,
he found a bunch of
different actual Greasers,
who were now grown-up adults,
and made us go spend the
night and live with them.
They came to us at rehearsal,
and so, we're gonna divide you up.
Rob, Tom, you guys are gonna go stay with
Bill and Sandy Webber.
And we just went to their
little house and had dinner.
- Oh my Gosh, this could've gone
very Dateline Special though.
Like you know--
- Oh Tom and I ended up in the basement.
In two cots.
And we're like, we
don't know these people.
I mean, who vetted them?
You think Francis Ford
Coppola spent a lot of time
vetting these people?
I can tell you, he didn't.
He was with an espresso,
watching some fancy Fellini movie,
and he went, yeah yeah that sounds great.
And went back to his espresso.
- Meanwhile, you had to live it.
- At two o'clock in the
morning in their basement.
- That's amazing.
It's an awesome story.
I will listen to your
podcast for this story alone.
Cause it's scary and I
would've been like, I'm out.